Speaker 1: Let's talk now about Florida. Florida
is a state where incumbent Republican Senator
Marco Rubio is trying to stave off a challenge
from a Democratic congresswoman, Val Demings. If
I voted in Florida, I would vote for Demings over
Marco Rubio. Marco Rubio appeared on CNN over the
weekend. He sounded very, very sick. Hopefully
it's not COVID and just the cold, but he sounded
ill and he was confronted about the fact that in
the past he has voted against funding for other
states when they are hit with a national natural
disaster. But now he wants money for Florida
when it's his state recovering from Hurricane
Ian. Now, to remind everybody in my audience,
I think they all should get the federal funds
for disaster relief. But what we're talking
about here is hypocrisy. Now, when Dana Bash
confronts Rubio with this hypocrisy, he tries
to pull some weird pork thing. And Dana Bash,
good for her, is prepared for it and she calls
it out for the lie that it is. Check this out.
Speaker 5: Senator, you wrote a letter Friday
to the Senate Appropriations Committee asking
for disaster relief dollars for desperately
needed resources to rebuild Florida communities.
After Hurricane Sandy hit northeastern states
in 2012. You voted no on a $50 billion relief
package. I know you supported a smaller version,
but why should other senators vote for
relief for your state when you didn't
vote for a package to help theirs? Right.
Oh, I've always voted for hurricane disaster
relief. I've even voted for it without pay
force. But I didn't vote for it, Sandy,
because they had included things like a
roof for a museum in Washington, D.C.,
for fisheries in Alaska. It had been loaded up
with a bunch of things that had nothing to do with
disaster relief. And I wouldn't support disaster
relief efforts. I would never put out there that
we should go use a disaster relief package for
Florida as a way to pay for all kinds of other
things people want around the country. So I think
that's the key in moments like this. And Sandy,
unfortunately, they loaded it up. They really did
with a bunch of things that had nothing to do with
Sandy. But get ready. I voted for every disaster
relief package, especially that's clean and I'll
continue to do so when it comes to Florida.
I'll do that again and we'll make sure that
that package is clean and doesn't have stuff for
other people in there. I read the Congressional
Research Service report last night. It sounds like
that roof actually was damaged by the hurricane
and what happened in alaska.
Speaker 1: Turns out it
wasn't a random roof, marco.
Speaker 5: The result of another
disaster. But in any event, what my question
is about the future. Are you telling me that
if hurricane and relief contains anything
that smells like pork, you'll vote? No?
Sure, I'll fight against it. Having pork in it.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, that's a different thing.
You'll fight against it, but you'll vote for
it. In this particular case, this is not unique
to Rubio, not like in Rubio's defense. I mean,
we're talking about Rubio because it's Florida.
He represents Florida. But this is really common
over the last decade on this program, it's been,
what, a dozen times, two dozen times that I've
come to you all with peace and love and tears in
my eyes. And I've said to you, here is another
elected official from Oklahoma. Oklahoma just
got hit with tornadoes, this very same Oklahoma
official when it was Superstorm Sandy affecting
New York and New Jersey. They voted against
it. And now they're saying, give me the money,
please. We need it for the people. These
are hypocrites and there's dozens of them.
And it's not unique to Marco Rubio, but Marco
Rubio is the guy running for reelection right
now and checking in on the polling there. It's
not great, but it's not terrible. Marco Rubio
leading Val Demings on average by 2.8 percentage
points within reach. Within reach. And of course,
all these guys and I do mean Rubio and DeSantis
all of a sudden they're friendly with Biden and
they're all in favor of relief because they
don't want to lose their office because of a
disastrous botched reaction to Hurricane
Ian. That's their priority right now.